in terms of
non-history books the book that probably
had the most
impact on me which is also a historical
nonfiction
is i am obsessed
with antarctic exploration and it all
began
with a book called shackleton's
incredible journey
which is the collection of diaries of
everybody who was
on shackleton's journey for those who
don't know shackleton was the
last explorer of the heroic age of
antarctic exploration
he led a ship called the endurance
which froze in the ice off the coast of
antarctica
in 1914 and
they didn't have radios or the last
exploration a last one without the age
of radio
and he happens to freeze in the ice and
then
the ship collapses after a year frozen
in the ice
and this man leads his entire crew
from that ship onto the ice with a team
of dogs
survives out on the ice for another year
with three little lifeboats and is able
to get
all of his men every single one of them
alive to an
island hundreds of miles away called
elephant island
and when they got there he had to leave
everybody
behind except for six people and him
and two other guys i'm forgetting their
names
navigated by the stars 800 miles through
the drake passage with seas
of hundreds of feet to prince i think
it's called prince george's island
and then when they got to prince
george's island they landed on the wrong
side
and they had to hike from one side to
the other
to go and meet the whalers and every
single one of those things was supposed
to be impossible
nobody was ever nobody was ever supposed
to hike that island it wasn't done again
until like the 1980s
with professional equipment he did it
after two years of starvation
nobody was ever supposed to make it from
elephant island to prince the guy they
had to hold him steady his legs
so that he could chart the stars and if
they miss this island
they're into open sea they're dead and
then before that
how do you survive for a year on the ice
yeah on seals
and before that he kept his crew
from depression frozen one year in the
ice
it's just an amazing story and it made
me obsessed
with antarctic exploration so i've read
like 15 books on what the hell is it
about the human spirit that's amazing
that's that's the thing about antarctica
is it brings it out of you
so for example i read another one
recently called mawson's will
douglas mawson he was an australian he
was on the or one of the first
shackled uh frost robert frost
expeditions he leads
an expedition down to the south him and
a
partner they're leading uh exploration
since 1908 something like that
they're going around antarctica with
dog teams and one of the what happens is
they keep
going over these snow bridges where
there's a crevice but it's covered in
snow
and so the one of the the lead driver
the dogs go over and they plummet and
that sled
takes with it so the guy survives but
that sled takes
all their food half the dogs their
stove the camping tent
the tent specifically designed for the
snow everything
and they're hundreds of miles away from
base camp
he and this guy have to make it back
there in time
before the ship comes to come get them
on an agreed-upon date
and he makes it but the guy he was with
he dies
and it's a crazy story they have first
of all they have to eat the dogs the a
really creepy part of antarctic
exploration is everyone
ends up eating dogs at different points
yeah um
and part of the theory which is so crazy
is that
the guy he was with was dying because
they were eating dog liver and dog liver
has a lot of vitamin e
which if you eat too much of it can give
you like a poisoning
and so uh mawson by trying to help his
friend was giving him more
of all the things that kills you i know
it's dog liver
and so his friend ends up dying have a
horrific heart attack
all of that mauson crawls back hundreds
of miles away
makes it back to base camp hours after
the ship leaves
and two guys or a couple guys stayed
behind for him
and he basically has to recuperate for
like six months before he can even walk
again
but it's like you're saying about the
human spirit it's like antarctica
brings that out of people or amundsen
the guy who made it to the south pole
robert amundsen oh my god like this guy
trained his whole life in the ice
from norway to make it to the south pole
and he beat robert frost the british guy
with all this money
and all these i could go on this forever
you